de comedia las autoridades
estadounidenses el reconocimiento a los
periodistas y la guerra en ucrania
fueron los temas que marcaron la primera
cena de la asociación de corresponsales
de la casa blanca a la que asiste un
presidente en seis años luego del boicot
al evento que el ex presidente de donald
trump protagonizó a partir de 2017 joe
biden no dudó en recordar sólo a la
audiencia
es la primera vez que el presidente
asiste a esta escena en seis años es
comprensible tuvimos una horrible plaga
seguida por dos años de kobe
saliendo del tono humorístico advertido
de peligros al orden mundial liberal y a
nivel local de amenazas para democracia
y todo esto tiene lugar con esta
desinformación en aumentos donde la
verdad es enterrada por las mentiras y
las mentiras viven como la verdad
reiterar el lugar de una prensa libre en
eeuu a diferencia de otros lugares del
mundo dio pie a recordar el
enfrentamiento tácito con rusia
la buena noticia es que ahora puedes
burlarte del presidente de eeuu y a
diferencia de moscú no irás a la cárcel
fue el turno de bailén de someterse a
las bromas del anfitrión de brno a si no
hubieras venido lo habría entendido
totalmente sí sí porque esta gente ha
sido muy dura contigo lo cual no
entiendo realmente no lo entiendo creo
que desde que llega hasta el cargo las
cosas están mejorando la gasolina ha
subido el alquiler ha subido la comida
ha subido de bailén recordó a los
periodistas que perdieron la vida en los
últimos meses cubriendo la guerra
ucraniana y bromeó sobre su baja
popularidad que ahora ronda el 40 por
ciento esto de cara a unas elecciones de
medio término en la que los demócratas
podrían perder sus mayorías en el
congreso
un eventual resultado que sin duda le
borraría la sonrisa del rostro